bonjour messieurs et merci d'être en
direct avec nous c'est donc une nouvelle
journée de mobilisation contre le pass
sanitaire 7e week-end consécutif avec
une mobilisation qui est un petit peu en
baisse mais toujours au rendez vous
malgré les vacances d'été le
gouvernement doit-il sont inquiétés
stéphane rozès
le gouvernement les observateurs
sont enregistrés qu'il y avait une
minorité importante
qui s'exprimait contre le pass
sanitaires oui ou l'obligation et
l'obligation vaccinale c'est une donnée
maintenant
intégrée
du point de vue du gouvernement ou ne
voit pas qu'il change
d'attitude et de politique sanitaire
sans inquiéter le climat autour de ces
questions n'est pas bonnes donc en
termes de morale pour le pays tout ça
n'est pas une bonne affaire mais il n'y
a au fond des sujets d'inquiétudes
sanitaires
économiques sociaux
il y à une rentrée politique est au fond
l'inquiétude est un peu partout et le
gouvernement tente de montrer qu'il
maîtrise une situation fort instable qui
rend la plupart des personnes inquiètes
dans la tente en espérant tenir les
différentes contraintes au quotidien
vous décrivez donc une situation fort
instable que quand pensez-vous j'ai le
casanova selon vous comment devrait
réagir le gouvernement face à cette
mobilise pour rendre à de l'ampleur à la
rentrée
je ne suis probablement pas le meilleur
conseil pour le mais cependant
la chose sur laquelle ils devraient
réfléchir c'est l'idée de ce passeport à
point pour la vie sociale c'est sans
lien avec la santé ça pourrait être
demain attribué à un autre sujet et ça a
été quelque chose
présenté par les consultants américains
notamment de mckinsey qui vont
travailler avec les autorités chinoises
sur le crédit social c'est-à-dire ce
dispositif qui fait que si vous vous
comportez bien selon le gouvernement
chinois vous pouvez voyager assez loin
sinon vous êtes à peu près confiné chez
vous êtes indépendamment de questions
sanitaires et là on est dans la même
question et c'est celle qui est
explosive qui fait que le mouvement
auquel on assiste rassemble des gens de
toutes les catégories sociales il y à
des jeunes il y à des vieux il y à des
pauvres il ya des riches ni à des gens
très différents mais qui sont portées
par cette idée d'un passeport sociale
qui va les autoriser à avoir une vie
sociale à proportion de
[Musique]
l'exécution qu'ils feront des consignes
gouvernementales
qu'est ce qui dit que ce pass sanitaire
ne sera pas
désactivé pour ceux qui n'auront pas la
troisième dose de noël et qu'ils seront
interdits de sortie à noël s'ils n'ont
pas la troisième dose c'est à dire que
on voit comment ce dispositif peut
ensuite s'installer dans la durée dans
la société je vous rappelle que le plan
vigipirate a été mis en place pour trois
semaines à titre exceptionnel il ya 27
ans et qu'il est toujours en place et ça
c'est une inquiétude dans la société et
je vous dirais surtout
écoutez olivier verrons écoutez emmanuel
macron il y a deux mois lorsqu'il
s'agissait de faire voter le modem pour
le pass sanitaire dans sa première
version et ils ont indiqué pourquoi la
société de ray pas admettre son
extension au café au cinéma au
restaurant on au tgv à l'avion et bien
ce qu'ils ont dit à ce moment là moi je
voudrais dans ce cas si j'ai un conseil
à leur donner qu'il se réécoute eux
mêmes parce qu'ils comprendront pourquoi
la société ne peut pas admettre cette
méthode disons plus classique dans les
régimes totalitaires communistes que
dans les démocraties
stéphane rozès c'est vous vous êtes
d'accord vous estimez que mettre en
place ce pas sanitaire dès le départ
c'était de toute façon une mauvaise
stratégie de la part du gouvernement
un show pensiez évidemment nous ne
sommes pas en dictature où
j'étais corps pour répondre directement
à vos questions
personnellement
je j'étais favorable
du pot si je me classais du point de vue
des gouvernants à une vaccination
obligatoire mais hostile impasse
sanitaires effectivement dans
l'opposition
il ya différentes choses parmi les
opposants - ya les anti système
pour des raisons politiques idéologiques
de crainte
de fantasmes sont de toute façon hostile
à l'idée que le politique puisse dans
des sites et ceux politiques ces
gouvernants puissent prendre des mesures
qui ont effectivement un caractère
exceptionnel parce que la situation est
elle les opposants vaccin qui au nom du
principe de précaution
n'ayant pas selon une visibilité
suffisant disons que par prendre de
risques pillet les opposants ou pas ce
sont les arguments qui viennent d'être
énoncé qui sont inquiets d'un devenir
possible des libertés individuelles par
rapport aux politiques
sanitaires j'entendais un des
manifestants
l'arrêt est nickel tél c'est que ni la
société ni la police ni les politiques
ni les gouvernants n'était absolument
préparer à ce qui advient ce qui advient
c'est une maladie
un virus
qui prend toutes mes sociétés
par en bas
et qui rend configure les organisations
le rapport à la vie à la mort aux
politiques publiques et qui entraîne
d'ailleurs un retour du politique sur
l'économie cet événement cette
expérience auquel personne ne
s'attendait
évidemment bouscule tout le monde et
chacun les gouvernants chaque pays selon
sa culture
selon ces représentations
réagit différemment
en démocratie le politique a les moyens
et doit s'adapter à des situations la
situation il ya un mois n'était pas la
situation actuelle tout simplement parce
que le virus mute et moi je donne
crédit aux politiques fussent ils
pourvu qu'il soit plutôt
démocratique dans sa façon d'être
d'avoir à gérer des situations
d'urgence parce que si j'étais
gouvernants j'essaierai de trouver les
meilleures solutions ce qui ne veut pas
dire que en matière de politique cette
terre tout ce qui est fait est fait
forcément de façon raisonnable le foot
il dit ma position sur le free wheels
casanova vous pensez également qu'une
autre solution aurait pu être trouvé
pour mettre fin à la crise sanitaire une
autre solution que pas sanitaires
ample de l'espagne le conseil
constitutionnel espagnol a censuré
purement et simplement la loi
adoptée par le parlement espagnol
toujours sous l'influencé des mêmes
consultants américains et qui instaurait
un pass sanitaires il a été jeune
rejeter complètement se passe sanitaire
est bien calé le résultat aujourd'hui
l'espagne est le pays européen le plus
vacciner parce qu'à partir du moment où
vous inciter à la vaccination en
expliquant à quel point ça va aider la
société à sortir de l' inquiétude sur ce
virus même si ce n'est pas parfait même
si ça ne résout pas tous les problèmes à
partir du moment où vous avez été comme
l'ont été les dirigeants espagnols
contraints par leurs autorités de dire
la vérité les problèmes auxquels ils
étaient confrontés est bien la
population si elle est traitée comme
adultes alors elle comprend elle peut
agir au contraire si elle est traitée
comme un animal de compagnie à qui on
donnera un susucre s'il a fait
exactement ce qu'on lui dit de faire il
y a toutes chances pour qu'ils se
rebiffent et que au contraire cela
renforce la prévention contre le vaccin
lui même puisque ça donne le sentiment
que si on utilise de telles méthodes
c'est que le vaccin lui même n'est
peut-être pas exactement ce qu'on nous
dit et puis un autre aspect en france
quel est le problème des personnes non
vaccinées c'est que ce sont les
catégories sociales les plus populaires
les moins riches les moins formés les
moins instruites et le pass sanitaires à
qui ils s'adressent pas à eux eux ne
vont pas au restaurant ils ne prennent
pas le tgv ils ne prennent pas l'avion
ils ne vont pas au cinéma donc le pass
sanitaires il est fait pour mettre ou
pas les catégories urbaine de classes
moyennes qui font l'opinion et pour leur
donner l'habitude d'obéir et bien cette
idée là ne leur plaît pas c'est pourquoi
on trouve ces classes moyennes urbaines
dans la rue en ce moment évidemment avec
d'autres qui sont contre les vaccins en
général
tout un ensemble de choses qui se mêlent
mais dans une protestation contre un
gouvernement se mêle toujours de l'ombre
une chose on parlait d'une catégorie
plutôt populaire anp qui s'insurge
contre le passage iter mais ne faisons
pas de généralités il ya aussi des
scientifiques qui qui sont qui se
présentent également qu on voudrait vous
poser une autre question sur ces profils
divers en justement parmi les
manifestants est-ce qu'il n'est pas
aussi important justement de répondre à
leur inquiétude on a parfois
l'impression qu'ils sont plutôt moquer
alors que certains ne sont pas contre la
vaccination mais surtout donc le pass
contre le pass and i ter et l'obligation
vaccinale séphane rozès
depuis le départ
j'étais
hostile à l'idée pour accélérer la
vaccination d'organiser un système au
fond de deux passes de nas
au fond sous la contrainte
amenant sous la contrainte des champs à
changer de conduite alors que le
politique doit prendre ses
responsabilités
si le vaccin sauvent des vies ce que je
crois il doit
avoir un traitement égalitaire des
citoyens c'est la première chose la
seule bonne chose pour avoir travaillé
sur l'utilisation des données des data
sur la mutualisation des données des
dates à
la question
de
l'utilisation des données en matière de
sortie ne peut pas se faire sans une
explication
préalable des tenants et aboutissants de
politique kim tillie si des données de
santé en matière de politique sanitaire
la façon française
le s'approprier ces questions est très
singulière des travaux ont été faits que
les est menée par exemple pour occitanie
data qui a des opérateurs publics et
privés ou des citoyens ont été appelés
à donner leur avis sur le fait que des
données personnelles puissent être
utilisés pour des raisons de santé
publique et il y a eu dont la façon de
procéder des maladresses effectivement
nous devons distinguer les questions de
maladresse dans les façons de faire de
la question de fond si les différends en
matière de politique sanitaire merci
c'est en effet un autre sujet qu'on aura
peut-être l'occasion d'aborder lors d'un
autre débat merci beaucoup gilles
casanova je rappelle que vous êtes
expert en stratégie et communication et
merci à vous également stéphane rozès
politologue et enseignant à hec et
sciences-po merci beaucoup d'avoir
participé à ce débat